german chancellor angela merkel has
cancelled plans for a
stricter pandemic shutdown over the
easter break
following an unexpected crisis meeting
with state leaders
mackel said the hastily drawn up plans
were our own mistake
this comes just a day after leaders had
announced a five-day hard lockdown
from april 1st which would have shut
most shops and church services
but they faced criticism and confusion
over how the measures
would have been enforced there was also
anger at
domestic holidays being restricted while
some international trips
were still allowed here's chancellor
mackel speaking at a press conference
just a short while ago
a mistake must be acknowledged as such
and above all
it must be corrected as soon as possible
at the same time i'm well aware that
this entire situation
is causing added uncertainty i deeply
regret this
and i ask all citizens to forgive me
let's bring in our chief political
editor michelle who's following this
story for us michelle head of government
claiming her own decision was a mistake
asking for forgiveness even that's
highly unusual isn't it
yes that's quite a remarkable move it
was a statement she didn't take any
questions and the last time she did this
was
when she made a statement against russia
over the navalny
poisoning um at the same time this is
rather unique because she stressed that
this was her mistake and her mistake
alone
after all this is a piece of paper
virtually signed off on by all 16 state
premiers here in germany
it was her late night proposal and that
in the effectively ended almost 12 hours
of negotiations
and what appears to be an issue over her
leadership
style we're hearing criticism all around
that this simply popped up that people
didn't have a chance
and to see what is coming also german
industry pushing back german churches
were not consulted
after and then suddenly being asked not
to hold services
on the most important day for christians
and so this all amounted to a policy
roll back now and this very very public
apology clearly from a leader who is no
longer in the race for the next
elections that may well make a
difference this certainly damages
her leadership wallam stop since the
majority of germans were still behind
an ever tougher lockdown so what else
beside this apology what else did mackel
say factually
[Music]
well basically for now she's sticking
with the formula that was hammered out
and looking at the seven-day incidence
rates here in germany that emergency
break which will roll back some of the
openings
that had been agreed on will now kick
into place um
all around the country but it certainly
isn't a picture of unity at all
and it actually raises more questions
that need to be debated
still open is what happens about foreign
trips
this is something that angela mack was
also set against and this only added to
the confusion that germans were able to
travel to majorca
while they were not able and still
unable to travel within their own state
i would expect some more clarification
there but clearly there's an
end to mackel leading this crisis
management
this is all quite clearly and visibly
and tangibly for everyone now
down to every individual state something
she wanted to avoid
right at the beginning of this crisis
and throughout
you just mentioned it is she just maybe
uh saying that she's fed up and this
she's saying to the uh the state
premiers i've had enough of this
and you deal with it
no that's not her style at all she's a
woman who
very much emphasizes the duty she's a
moderator and she likes to
forge consensus this was very unusual
for her to spring this upon her state
premieres in the middle of the night
and it clearly backfired not just on her
but also
on those individual state premiers
although there were some applause from
experts also from the medics association
here in germany which felt that this
wave breaker lockdown was needed
so this is more and more about
leadership style
rather than the concrete results of this
gathering
and it raises yet more questions which
will now be solved
very much regionally so it's a it's a
shift in how germany deals with this
crisis
and it clearly is a crack uh in angela
mackel's
leadership while this living legacy that
she is
um and it raises a lot of questions how
she will
try to lead this over the coming months
because she's lost a lot of credibility
here
michaela kuvner chief political editor
there thank you for this analysis
michaela just mentioned the medical
profession and let's uh
speak now to dr uber younces he's the
head of the german association of
critical care and emergency uh medicine
dr johnson
looks like the easter shut down is going
to be isn't going to be as strict as we
expected what do you make of this u-turn
now
what does it mean for you
so the german internet association of
critical comments and then
emergency medicine we said weeks ago
before the last meeting of chancellor
merkel
with prime ministers of the 16 states
that we said
to go on with a lockdown
until end of march the decision
three weeks ago was too open
so we acknowledge that the infection
rates rises
daily and now we are above 100 incidents
for per hundred thousand seven days so
um it was clear that they had to stuck
to the decisions three weeks ago
we also said that this was quite
a good decision to do a wave breaker
lockdown as
your correspondent just named it
over the easter days but on the other
hand
we have to acknowledge that the
decisions seem to be
not very popular and many people
politicians and as well the inhabitants
of
germany they are not quite satisfied
with this decision
so i was quite astonished to just hear
this new decisions and that
will mean and that was quite good
formulated by your
uh correspondent berlin the ups and
downs in this decision and
at this moment i think uh everybody is
dazzled and
we are we are looking in the next days
our obligation as physicians is
to heal people to save
them from covet 19. we are not
politicians
the decisions which are to be made
they should secure the people from
getting the infections
and can i just interrupt you there
without these strict
lockdown measures in place what are you
seeing
coming for german hospitals and how far
away are they from breaking point
especially the intensive care units
so uh we we see that the last seven to
ten days the numbers of covet-19
patients is rising uh
not as quick but they the number is
rising so
if you don't start to lock down
you let the people go without any
stopping and go to shops we will see
that
the infection rates will rise so um
professor wheeler from the robert koch
institute stated
two weeks ago that he fears that the
number of infections per day
will be above 30 000 a day around about
easter that would be quite much
at the moment 2.5 to 3 percent of these
numbers will um need intensive care
therapy so this would be a high number
to 40 days after easter so in the
intensive care medicine we always
uh see the developments and 10 to 14
days later we see what happens with
intensive care medicine so
we said at the moment we have rising
figures
and we must state that the british
mutation the b117 is
quite much more infectious and
it seems to be more aggressive so we
have
um a lot of old people vaccined
at this moment but the people between 60
and 80
years they are not vaccinated so they
are
at risk and we fear that they get the
infection of the b117
and that will take a bad cause when they
get covet 19.
dr ub janssen thank you very much for
taking the time to talk to us
you